we have reached it folks we have reached
that time I'm not looking forward to
reviewing a Star Wars movie still going
to though we're gonna get through this
trying time
[Music]
solo is Star Wars story so soul of a
Star Wars story is the origin story of
Han Solo that no one really asked for
and then when Lord and Miller the
original directors made a version of
this movie no one asked for that
Kathleen Kennedy didn't like chic and
them then brought in Ron Howard and now
he's directed solo a Star Wars story and
essentially the plot is we get to see
Han Solo get everything we know about
Han Solo but among that plot Han Solo
joins a crew in which they have to get
this item news a item and had to deliver
it to Paul Bettany supercrime box I'll
say this about alden ehrenreich who
plays home solo dude was better than i
thought it was gonna be that's probably
because i really thought he was gonna
suck who's in all the trailers he just
didn't impress me but there were a
couple moments Rawls like that does seem
like young Han Solo good on him credit
where credit's day but he doesn't stand
out it's not like I'm like Alden
Ehrenreich only dude who could have done
it feel like there are a few people who
could have played home so it would have
been just as fine the Twitter chatter
has told you Donald Glover is the best
part of the movie it's probably true he
probably does do the best job don't know
what that means I mean you compare him
to everyone else you're like he's he's
just much better than a lot of years
well disclosure I am a huge Donald
Glover fan childish gambino has
solidified himself as the working artist
of our time
I love the do maybe my love for dog
lovers making it like nah he's so good
as Landa I don't think that's it because
I genuinely think he was great as Lando
yeah charm he had charisma granted
before we meet him we are told he is
charming and has charisma the funny
cinema trick they did there but I
thought he was good also I do like the
Han meeting Chewie thing I guess if
there is one meeting that's the meeting
you don't want to screw up in this movie
I actually like them meeting and it does
harken back to the legends lore but
really the pacing in this movie sucks
and the movie just comes across as
worried the movie is boring you might
hear some flag terms like it's a fun
summer adventure it's not it can't be
fun because the pacing sucks this matter
what season is meant for the first act
of this movie is a mix of our owners
token oil to get going and then it's
like alright time John but it doesn't
fix the pacing it just makes the pacing
shot here like alright that's bad pacing
end time John cruel and I don't know
what they kept from the Lord and Miller
cut and the Ron Howard cut me Ron Howard
is credited as the director of this
movie so I just assumed he refilmed the
movie from the ground up but there are a
couple of moments where it's like are I
supposed to be sentimental moment
oh all right I'm over it let's go do
something else okay did you give a [ __ ]
so the conflict in town and conflict and
pacing could be the result of two
different directing styles clashing or
it could be the result of the director
of in the heart of the sea bringing his
pacing to the game that's actually kind
of harsh this movie does have better
pacings in the [ __ ] whale movie that
Ron Howard director
so not good not good for a heist movie I
mean there's a scene where they're on
this planet they're doing the job and
then just an action sequence breaks out
and it came across like that conveyor
belt scene in attack of the clones like
the story is george lucas was like this
needs something else there and you just
wrote in a conveyor belt saying came
across like shed from a video game where
you fight jowenko the lava bees it came
across like that i feel like they were
filming the movie they were like they're
doing the job nothing's really happening
something is to happen here all right
we'll just do this and get an action
sequence going it doesn't organically
weave it doesn't flow with the movies
detonators are flying laser blasts are
going and it happens because it's Star
Wars and that's what happens in a star
war granted resistance when pulling off
a heist is going to happen it's expected
just so happens that what they ran into
wasn't resistance it was just an action
sequence an action sequence that wasn't
really the result of them doing their
Heights could it have happened more
organically with the film yeah one of
the things the movies really lacking is
a real antagonist this movie has no real
bad guy it is a space heist film will
take Ocean's eleven for example there's
no Andy Garcia character even when Andy
Garcia wasn't on screen you knew they
just had to avoid this guy at all cost I
was bad news don't let him say this
movie doesn't have that character I'll
bet he's in a scene and a half and he's
just he's worlds away there is this
[ __ ] who comes around and causes
problems a couple times that's not the
main threat the main threat in this
movie is time I have to get the
merchandise and deliver it in a certain
amount of time a merchandise timing
itself that's the real threat it's the
most boring villain ever but you take
rogue one the chronic was that guy you
take the original Star Wars movies Darth
Vader is that guy force awakens kylo Ren
is that guy this is like if the force
awakens happen silo Ren wasn't in the
movie at all and just Huck saturon was
in a scene in a ham and Captain phasma
showed up a couple times and did a
couple things
those were your villains I did like Paul
Bettany when he was on screen like if
Paul Bettany had more screen time I
probably would have enjoyed this movie
more Paul Bettany seems like the one
who's having fun in this movie oh hey
man donald glover holy [ __ ] I forgot
Woody Harrelson was even in the movie
until just now like watch world we live
in we're Rudy hair
character doesn't even stand out really
what carries this movie are the
references this movie is constructed for
you to see something happen with Han
Solo that ties back to Han Solo that we
know from the original trilogy so you
can be like the Captain America meme
from the Avengers and be like I
understood that reference that's it
that's really what carries his movie
like Deadpool to a movie I enjoyed does
rely on references also what the
references really are our jokes Deadpool
- relies on jokes so happens a lot of
those jokes in that movie our fourth
wall breaking references references in
han Solo aren't jokes they don't make
you laugh they make you go that's not
enough to carry a movies not enough to
make a good movie I mean the movie has a
couple good moments of banter it has one
chase sequence in particular is probably
the only chase sequence I remember in
the movie it is actually pretty good
movie by the end is just really
predictable this movie springboards off
of the flaws of Star Wars movies that
have come before it not the strength
this is essentially just pick a generic
sci-fi movie slap a Star Wars label on
it that's this movie but if new Star
Wars movies are meant for a new
generation I feel like a new generation
deserves better than this I'm not gonna
remember this movie in fact I'm not
gonna remember this movie in t-minus one
day yep or deeper guys Sam's Korra gave
attack of the clones take it as you will
alright so solo a Star Wars story are
you looking forward to it what are you
hoping to say whatever you think comment
below let me know and as always if you
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
you all look great today if I told you
that I comment sections gonna be fun
[Music]